[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talked about
whatever we want we were just talking
about
cummies dude you can't sleep on
companies dude
good fundamentals endless supply
you know what i mean endless supply
inflate [ __ ]
nah that didn't work as well
no no it is crazy that kryptos going
nuts
and i think angels the angel stadium
said they'll start taking doge to
they'll sell tickets if you buy it in
douche that's so hard cuba and mark
cuban's doing that i think oakland a's
too
what's the deal with dogecoin is it
legit or what i mean
what's what's money is it legit i think
i think i think i figured can't they
just print as much money as they [ __ ]
want
yeah we all know they can't so yeah they
can print as much dogecoin as they want
too
and a lot of people who are in crypto
like myself you can be
you can find yourself get snobby about
this [ __ ] sometimes but then
you start to realize that our money is
the same scam so
everyone who laughs about dogecoin i
think that the argument can be made for
us dollars the same way
how how is it increasing in price if
it's like on this supply
there's huge institutions buying it up
there's a lot of retail investors buying
it so it's all hype
also it's an endless supply but it's not
an endless supply like immediately
there's like a maximum amount that can
be
minted a year so if like the more people
buy into it then
will be bought or minted in that year
then technically it can increase in
value you don't
get to 70 billion dollars though from
just people hyping something like
there's definitely some
institutional support to this thing so
it's legit
i mean you know it's funny to say that
but it it's i think it is yeah
if enough people have their fiat in it
then it becomes legit that's all it is
it's kind of like um even at a bubble
right we're like what do you call it
this is happening huh it's like pets.com
or any kind of [ __ ] during the
[Music]
yeah like if people put their money in
it it
i guess like it holds i pulled out my
dogecoin last night
there's gonna be winners and losers
though that's the thing with investing
you know
i hope i don't follow and it goes up and
then i'm gonna cry it's gonna go to a
dollar i think
i might cry it's not like 57 right now
right was that like 60 or 70 the other
day it was
like 65 cents yeah did you guys uh start
creating your list of what kind of [ __ ]
you're gonna buy what's your list
yeah you go first yeah we do want to
hear joseph's first i have a list
i'm not going to tell you but you should
tell me that's like eating dessert first
i don't know if i want to do that
i've only got like a list of debt that i
got to pay off
that's true the taxes is first i have to
set aside the taxes first that's key
why you guys so normal dude what are you
gonna buy what are you gonna buy dude
like [ __ ] you money style man well
you guys know about the billboard idea
right we're all going to get billboards
we're going to have a whole line of us
just [ __ ]
butt naked in the cape saying [ __ ] you
pay me after we pay the taxes
that's right yeah i don't want to buy
the billboard and the taxes come oh
[ __ ] i spent on the billboard and the
public nudity charge too we have to pay
that fee as well
very responsible irresponsible we're
gonna start an advertising agency
okay buy all that stuff first because
it's a write-off and then we're gonna
pay
taxes i'm going to do nothing but well
you guys will only know i'll keep it to
this crowd okay but
i'm going to do a bunch of troll art and
i'm going to be dancing
so if you can see
you know who let's keep it down though
what about you dude
me yeah do you have any dreams
[Laughter]
yeah you got dreams fooled yeah what's
your dream
successfully pay off uh my girl's uh
grad school debt why you gotta do it
because when i'm like rolling in
so much tax-free dough
you know what i mean it'll just you know
like once
once i get like married it's like you
know you assume a little bit of the
responsibility
that a little bit i can't just be like
killing it and then she's like
worried about her like dead and stuff
isn't that the whole point of a marriage
though is like you
become more successful than your spouse
and you rub it in their face
you know what yeah you know what you
just inspired me
to not help her for sure yeah so she's
never going to learn if she doesn't pay
it off herself because
i hear from the government telling
everyone about student loans
this is true so if your crypto doesn't
pop off then it's
it are you guys still gonna try to pay
her no if it doesn't pop off then like
whatever she's
like earns when she like starts working
she's gonna have to pay for my [ __ ] it
doesn't pop off
yeah she's gonna be my sugar mama you
know what i mean
do you feel like it's the lotto and it's
like well i got it for free so i might
as well share it
absolutely emotionally absolutely yeah
but no
but staking this [ __ ] though it feels
awful good doesn't it it does it does
i think i don't think it would be
possible not to splurge
on like a large sum of money being
earned in a short amount of time
i don't think it would be possible in
any situation so what is your splurge
splurge you buy like a corvette or
something
right now i just buy more crypto okay um
let's say okay
to be i really really enjoy
the teslas i really enjoy them but right
now it's not responsible for me to go
get one
yeah if i made a good amount of money
yeah just go buy one of those batteries
go buy one you're going to get
all cash probably not i think the curse
of crypto for me is that when i think
about getting a tesla i'm like why am i
not putting that into bitcoin
exactly that's the problem i know but i
never get to read the benefits it's a
mental
thing it's just i know that's why we we
degen i'm kind of like steve a little
bit too because in the beginning
i was like why the [ __ ] does like bill
gates or warren buffett drive a camry
yeah i'm like you can buy a [ __ ] semi
truck
take all the seats out and you're the
only seat in it it doesn't even make
sense but you could do
you could do something i think i think
warren buffet is ridiculous though
warren buffet is ridiculous because like
bill gates he still like will have like
his
like 155 million dollar wedding back in
the day or something like that in the
90s and like
buy out private islands in hawaii in
order to like host he'll still do that
yeah warren buffett's like
unless he's got some real secret looks
like he's gonna [ __ ] die soon
yeah he just drives a suburban and he
has he doesn't even have a flat screen
tv
he still has box tvs in his house that's
how i feel about jay leno when he when
he's like yeah
not my tonight's show money i put it all
in the bank and i'm like dude like
aren't you like 70 bro like
it's time to live jay leno lives a lot
though
have you seen his car collection that's
true he's got like a museum
but that's all his stand-up money he
says so i'm like well dude just [ __ ]
use your tonight show money already like
i want to see what he does next
but like because of that i do start to
see like now
every time i'm putting like here's a
doll here's a summer money i'm like do i
want to spend it on something or put it
into something that could turn into
something else yeah i'm like i
understand
oh you guys are so poor i understand why
people
are billionaires and they drive a camry
now see see
with crypto i don't want to go like too
deep with this but i am going to
go deeper i don't feel like honestly i
don't even feel like it's just like oh
man i hope i make x amount of money
therefore i can do whatever i feel like
once like i really really got into it
it's just like a lifestyle change
yes it just makes you think about stuff
differently like i used to really geek
out and be like
uh i'll buy any tech if it's like the
newest and latest and coolest thing i'll
buy it just because it's really cool
i think apple like [ __ ] loves me yeah
you know what i mean because i just buy
[ __ ] just because it's upgraded just
because it's cool yeah the second like
you
you you get into that mentality like
well if i buy this like 400
apple watch i really could have just
bought a [ __ ] ton of v chain right now
you know what i'm saying it's like the
second you start understanding my
lifestyle you change everything now i'm
like
don't buy the coffee don't buy this
don't go shopping and then buy more
v-chain yeah like
yeah so i should buy a v-chain yeah hey
bro
hey bro bro oh [ __ ] that's what that is
he got a v-chain shirt
she didn't even notice that all day well
[ __ ] now i gotta buy it
he's already balling i'm like should i
buy the shirt should i buy the coins
this is the only thing i'm putting money
into is crypto shirts and and my cr
my hat collection now that's it
everything else is crypto
crypto hat crypto so i'm gonna buy some
v chain i'm gonna buy some
tara yeah but realistically like i said
like whether it's like crypto or
investing in general or the idea of like
getting your money to work for you and
like trying to like compound that as
quick as possible during a time in your
life but this is
now anthony what about 100 million
anthony
honestly like you're gonna tell me
you're gonna be like i'm not gonna buy
that tesla
i'm gonna buy more crypto i'll probably
buy a tesla um but i also probably would
like consider
this for the sake of conversation i'll
consider having a [ __ ] ton of kids if i
had [ __ ] money
why with different women no
i thought you were trying to be like
genghis khan over here
that's not socially acceptable so i'm
not going to go i know which crypto
genghis khan would have bought
coins cummies cummies
uh no dude i was just thinking about
this the other night because because
it's like yeah okay let's say
crypto i am let's say i have 100 million
dollars how much will my life be
different than it is right now nikki
just got us an inflatable [ __ ]
jacuzzi
dope in our in our backyard and we have
and we have a drink
machine that is as a bartender that
makes drinks for us
what and we were watching survivor the
other night
on a projector in our backyard in an
inflatable jacuzzi and i'm like i made
it already i don't even need crypt
that's living i did it it's [ __ ] dope
it's incredible
it is pretty good you should just give
us your crypto then i might
if you don't have the imagination to
spend your crypto money
might as well give it away you're saying
i'm wasting it huh yeah
okay what would you do i don't know you
got some milos to make up for a little
bit
true i've been driving the same
volkswagen jetta for the past night your
movie right make a
bunch of movies if i had ultimate
[ __ ] money i would i would [ __ ]
make movies
nothing worth fighting for was ever won
without sacrifice
this is a one-time gig when it's done
we're done
a touching reunion
[Music]
my name is yuffie it's nice to meet you
[Music]
no freaking way now
let the hunch begin
video is brought to you by final fantasy
7
remake integrate on the playstation 5
and guess
when it's dropping june 10th baby june
10th
yup they got all brand new super crisp
graphics improved textures in 4k
and then if you play in the performance
mode at 60 frames a second
bang who's that hot girl that's in the
in the game oh t
for [ __ ] oh my god such a big question
oh my goodness more beautiful more
realistic skin
this is it so if you're just as excited
about this game
as joe is you can pre-order it go to sq
ex dot link slash remake otr i know it's
hard but it's sq ex dot link slash
remake otr to pre-order
yours now because everyone that loves
final fantasy is probably gonna grab one
and you're gonna thank yourself if you
pre-order it mm-hmm
i know i am because you could make your
movie you got [ __ ] your money
yeah you can make your movie you can
have the marketing for your movie you
can actually buy
theaters like you can literally like do
whatever the [ __ ] you want you're gonna
need a lot dude true
with 100 mil that's only one movie you
can't keep it's very true
can't flirt with krypto anymore it's
time to start [ __ ] her dude it's time
to start [ __ ] her right
we're gonna we're gonna do it already
yeah we gotta get that [ __ ] now
hey if we all or when we all become like
100 millionaires
let's let's build our like really [ __ ]
up utopia but i'm not degen enough to
make 100 million
mine's like boring gains
i don't to say that because like that
doesn't inspire me but beyond that
once we all make our and you make your
10 millions and we all make our billions
because it's gonna happen yeah we gotta
have our utopia you know what i mean our
our joe malia's our participants are
places where we can do the [ __ ] you
stuff and not get judged because that's
the difference what is your [ __ ]
stuff
because you also fight you only said
tesla i think i said having a bunch of
kids
oh i think think about it like having a
child is probably gonna be like what a
million dollars
at least right yeah over time by the
time yeah that's what i'm saying over
time but if
and then imagine if you have so much
money that you don't have to take care
of your kids you can just get them
raised until they're like old enough to
like just work for you in that asian
household
and you gotta pay for their therapy
doing that yeah but it's [ __ ] you money
okay i get it one of the kids will
become the therapist why you want kids
then
i will need an army i need an army i
want a bunch of kids that someone else
takes care of you know what i'm saying
okay i know they're gonna fight for you
i want that family tree like a like a
fraternity like composite
wow where like just the old version of
myself with just like a dog named
blockchain and like a cat named like
on my lap and it's just like that's how
he made it you need to
adopt orphans they'll fight for you
because they'll know okay that works too
but they're still probably
gonna cost me some money yeah they will
this you know this isn't about me nick
when you're a billionaire
man mine's gonna be so boring what is
because i think i probably wouldn't
spend
any money dude i'm super frugal that
i'm like boring dude that's pretty
boring that's so boring yeah i'm boring
too i can't think of like you're asking
me i'm like i can't think of a single
thing i would want you travel we know
you would travel
but don't check aston martin's you
wouldn't get an aston martin aston
martin yeah but
if i had [ __ ] money i could probably
buy like a hundred of them then right
okay so you probably want to annual
oh yeah maybe three of them right i feel
like you're three of them pretty
considerate
when steve was talking about the
inflatable hot tub i'm like yeah i'm
cool with that
when he was talking about the bartender
i was like you would buy a bartender
oh you know anyone else is a massage
shirt massage chair is like to me is
like the height of luxury like the 5 000
all of these things you guys could buy
right now dude and also um
it matters we need to be billionaires
yeah yeah like chill joe oh and a fridge
like bart bart has a really cool fridge
at his house oh is it the double door
buddy
yeah but also it's a water dispenser
that tells you how many ounces of water
all of your dreams
you could you can get right now at
making like 80 000
electric mahjong table the one that like
re-does [ __ ]
we're gonna oh that's that's legit these
guys are like
oh my god if i had that kind of money i
would eat chicken every day
i'm talking about you don't want to have
[ __ ] bulldozer wars
we go in the desert i do we have [ __ ]
bulldozers gonna get hurt
like bumper cars with bulldozers
are we driving to a random city and we
just start crushing people's houses
and then when they start crying you just
throw a million dollars
why don't billionaires do that why don't
billionaires these are [ __ ] that's
why dude it's just random like 7 p.m we
just drive into [ __ ] monterey park
and you crush their house find houses
that are like 500 or 600 grand
and you just crush them yeah and then
just i still don't think 100 million is
gonna like
last long you know that's very
short-sighted
afterwards we asked each other why did
we get so mean
we sold out and then we throw them
underneath each other and go ahead never
mind [ __ ]
well i told joe this idea but we buy a
747
and then we tar and feather it so it
looks like a real eagle
we fly through the sky why can't air
force one look like that with a [ __ ]
beak on it
nobody would ever see them nobody would
they would fly over all the radars bro
yeah i need to up my imagination you're
an artist what happened to you
i'm going to pay off bills dude
imagine going into your yard and you you
see a feather and you're like holy [ __ ]
this is from air force one
it's [ __ ] amazing the american eagle
dude that's [ __ ]
it doesn't get any more american than
that made out of bald eagle feathers too
real fast dollar signs for the eyes
we're gonna name our kid that boy or
girl doesn't matter a good name yeah
luna it's a good name
or ada get it i do but i don't like the
ecosystem it's not it's gotta be it's
why the dog's gotta be named like
finance or some [ __ ]
finance
[Laughter]
or you do or you get real nerdy and you
do luna and then you do anchor and then
you
mirror and you do all the other
protocols so buy all that stuff
and blockchain i gotta catch up dude i'm
[ __ ] behind bro
i would pay my friends to hang out with
me those are called escorts
you already do that to suck your dick
all the time right well no because
if you think about it right what
prevents people from sticking together
in adulthood is you have to you guys
you got work got jobs that's true like i
was hanging out with my friends and i
was like thinking
oh yeah you guys got work today damn
that sucks
and i'm thinking well if i was rich you
got work dude that sucks bro
you're gonna go to work so you just have
an entourage yeah if i'm rich that's why
they have i'm like okay i just
how much do you need to survive 50 000 a
year all right cool
you work for me your [ __ ] job is to
hang out with me
we're gonna build a tribe and then we're
gonna buy
i saw this land out in maui it was about
like 600 acres it was this old branch
that they were selling
and they were selling that for about
like 30 million or something right
easy easy right yeah and then i'm like
right there that's i could build a theme
park here
and then my friends we could just build
mud huts or whatever
and then we could go fishing and i'm
like
i live on a bathroom somewhere else can
we do an indoor tribe
do we have to live in mud hut i'll build
a house this is my ac
if that's i'll build a house but then
like we can do other stuff right
and i don't know like because my i was
talking to my friend and he was like
you know be cool man he's like i want to
i want to just go spearfishing and
camping but i got work this week so i
got to schedule it out and i'm like
damn it sucks
[Laughter]
did you just keep on saying how much
your life sucks
joe's already on another level you're
like sucks bro
crazy wait what do you what do you mean
you have to get up tomorrow why
clock in what are you talking about like
to what
i'm like i'm not rich enough yet to free
all of them
but just enough to free myself you know
and it's so
it's it's it's not fair what's your
ideal entourage size mayweather
how many people do you roll like a
[ __ ] a crowd one thousand
nation bro and half of them are as kids
you know talk about it
mayweather has a duffel bag and then
some other guys have a duffel bag too oh
my god
damn how many duffel bags 10 million
people in my entourage that's a lot
don't you think that's like
every time you got to feed them
something you go to like like a dollar a
meal that's like 10 million every time
no but they get paid
i like the word behind your voice i like
i can see you getting the bill
i'm not getting the check by that time
we can be self-sustaining
you know what i mean we build farms we
build 1 000 bucks
when i have hundreds of millions of
dollars i'm going to build farms
that scares me he's like yeah when i get
all this money i'm going to have a
mushroom farmer so you already have one
right now
that's true what am i gonna do next
go to work he has a bunch of money he's
like maybe i should start working now
there's a lot of ways to live and
achieve your dreams without money
i think we figured it out though i
definitely want to be just mayweather
without the fighting
yeah just flying around cash a couple
people in my entourage
security guards yeah doing all the [ __ ]
but he doesn't even travel with anything
just buy his new [ __ ] there that's crazy
it's so sick i'll probably buy like a
mansion in vietnam for my parents
so that they would be forced to move
back
why you don't like them i think i think
in small doses it's really enjoyable
i know what you mean my mom's like
that's so funny distance is good
sometimes you know my mom
i'm over here trying to move to japan so
i could be with my mom and you guys
trying to run away
my mom my mom's like his mom i think
why can't a racist billionaire literally
send people back to china by buying a
bunch of property in china and then
giving them the property they go back to
china and it's not that bad
it's not that bad they could make their
dream come true yeah like oh my god
thank you this is amazing
this is the american dream like oh [ __ ]
that's so rich that you can
buy people to go back that's the
underrated american dream that nobody
talks nobody talks about this should be
a [ __ ] tv show
oh it's like extreme makeover bro it's
like undercover bosses
but it's like billionaire racist or
something it's like
[Laughter]
you can't see his face and he's and he's
the racist his voice is altered and [ __ ]
and that's perfect
he's got an asian accent yeah yeah it's
like blurred and dark
that'd be so tight and everyone has to
audition that's what network tv needs
bro none of this [ __ ] mass singer
[ __ ] how do you
audition just to be the worst like
minority in america
causing all the problems no the biggest
stereotype the biggest stereotype yeah
you